soir à michel raimbault la construction
d'infrastructures routières pourquoi une
telle accélération et pourquoi
maintenant on va écouter je pense que
c'est lié aux notamment nécessité de
boucler tous les toutes les promesses de
donald trump avant qu'il ne soit trop
tard que comme souvent mais dont je
pense que c'est dû aux incertitudes sur
les résultats des élections et aux etats
unis les prix des sites où l'on connaît
est donc finalement cebrian ça ajoute
beaucoup d'incertitudes à l'avenir il ya
les promesses est bonne
non pas que l'israélien puisse douter
des bonnes intentions de de joe biden si
c'est lui qui prend le pouvoir si celui
qui rentre à la maison blanche
mais en tout cas il faut mieux tenir que
de courir et dont il ya les promesses de
tromper je pense qu'ils veulent forcer
les feux ce qu'il ya plein de promesses
qui serait être vu un petit peu à la
baisse quand même donald trump a laissé
beaucoup de promesses et de cadeaux
disant en faveur d'israël sur des choses
qui ne lui appartenait pas comme le goal
ans comme la cisjordanie des
infrastructures sur les échos les
implantations et c'est la capitale
éternelle d'israël à jérusalem le
transfert de l'ambassade américaine je
pense qu'il s'agit de capitaliser tout
tous ces acquis et donc bon pour les
colonies 10 en cisjordanie et ils ont
dans les territoires palestiniens je
crois que s'il s'agit de créer nour est
accomplie et donc il faut des
infrastructures routières puisque
l'expérience prouve que temps que
finalement dans cisjordanie et on
hallucine façon générale dans les
territoires occupés tout ce qui a été
fait c'est toujours créé des faits des
faits des faits accomplis qui sont
irréversibles ensuite donc ça s'ajoute
cette inclus dans ces incidents
territoire israélien et comment il avait
terminé la messe est dite
je pense que ce qui est en crise où les
précisé michel raimbault qui ne
considère plus les colonies israéliennes
comme contraire au droit international
sa dauphine allemande on international
du tout donc finalement n'y a plus rien
qui soit contraire ni conforme au droit
est un gardien qui est conforme au droit
international
mais comme il ya plus de droit
international il est bien de faciliter
ces deux idées de dire ce qui est
contraire au droit international puis
s'il n'existe plus ou que tout le monde
fait enfin dix ans les états unis et
israël font comme si ce droit interne ça
n'existait plus sinon il y aurait pas eu
toutes ses promesses
on sait forcerait du temps de mettre en
oeuvre les résolutions des nations unies
et du conseil de sécurité qui prévoit
quand même une solution à deux états en
la solution à deux états est bien loin
il ya une solution à un seul état mais
les dieux a garanti depuis 1948
quant à ahwaz la solution de l'état
palestinien je vois pas très bien sur
quelle base territoriale il peut se
fonder sinon sur une prison à ciel
ouvert qu'est la bande de gaza mais sur
la cisjordanie et jérusalem je crois que
c'est fortement compromis
alors ça veut pas dire que ça fait
accompli les fait accompli ne sont
accomplies vraiment que lorsque c'est
accepté par les parties mais la banque
s'est pas être à pied par les
palestiniens mais je pense qu'en plus il
sera elle veut surfer si on peut dire
sur la grande vague d'amour qu'il porte
au moyen orient dont la vague
normalisation des états arabes notamment
avec le qatar avec l'arabie saoudite lui
avec le pardon le bas à laignes avec les
émirats arabes unis et puis avec le
sultan par exemple dans la région
et puis hop éventuellement derrière va
pas tarder à venir sans doute arabie
saoudite
il ya toute une vague de normalisation
et pour pour disons mettre en oeuvre ce
que ce qui avait été appelée la
transaction du siècle qui est
parfaitement accepté par la partie
israélienne n'est malheureusement pas du
tout parfum l'on prête pas du tout ça va
de soi par la partie palestinienne
organisation michel raimbault tel va en
être la conséquence on les conséquences
ça va rendre impossible à rendre ça va
rendre encore plus impossible je dirai
ce qu'il l'était déjà
c'est à dire une solution à deux états
puis la reprise y compris pour parler
les palestiniens veulent plus rien
entendre je trouve qu'ils ont été très
très patient même probablement trop
patient 10 ans d'attentes de ne vouloir
négocier à tout prix quelque chose qui
manifestement du côté d'israël n'est pas
négociable
je pense que ça n'a jamais été
l'intention d'israël finalement vu avec
du recul il n'a jamais été dans
l'intention d'israël finalement leur une
solution à deux états seulement de
gagner du temps et de profiter des
aubaines comme celle qui a été le mandat
de donald trump comme sont en fait les
aubaines de tous les présidents
américains et ce serait le cas de joe by
d'impôt pour l'avenir
disons d'abord des décisions favorables
ce rallye ça qu'ils sont défendent
descendu à 100% sans réserve que le
droit international n'existe plus
que bien rare rarissimes sont les états
qui expriment leur opposition y compris
que parmi les pays arabes ils sont pas
les seuls j'irai dans la communauté
internationale ou situe en tient lieu
avec des guillemets je pense qu'on ne
voit plus très bien un seul et à
s'opposer à la prise d'israël et donc
s'opposer à ce que décident les états
unis et de l'europe au le rôle de
l'europe écouter s'il y avait un rôle de
l'europe indépendante celui des
etats-unis et d'israël on ne saurait on
leur ait vue là je crois que bon
finalement c'est une scène peine perdue
même les étapes qui jadis dans
l'histoire l'histoire récente nous ne
sommes ni récentes comme la france avait
milité quand même assez nettement pour
la cause palestinienne et pour la
solution de la 2 état d'une solution à
deux états et arabes est un état juif je
pense que finalement c'est séduit c'est
du passé ça depuis d'un certain nombre
d'années déjà
la france a rejoint les rangs de la
banque atlantique et de combustion
nispel d'atlantisme il ya plus il ya
plus de aucune marge de manoeuvre
les palestiniens je sais pas sur quoi
ils peuvent compter donc lutter compter
sur une certaine unité mais ils ont mis
très longtemps à la réaliser entre les
mouvements islamistes qui vont pouvoir à
gaza et puis là l'autorité palestinienne
qui a tous les autres mouvements
quand tu vois ce genre d'ami ils ont mis
beaucoup de mal à s'unir et encore une
fois ya beaucoup de rivalité c'est très
très fine du mythe est très très fragile
et puis je crois qu'il est un petit peu
tard pour parler de yahya baya presque
plus de gens bien en cisjordanie haillan
et à jérusalem en tout cas il n'y a plus
de ya pratiquement plus de base
territoriale il ya des postillons comme
on dit deux de ses plus hauts depuis un
archipel avec des petits îlots de
palestiniens ccd vraiment des postillons
ce n'est des restes des traces et
bientôt il suffira d'un coup de
serpillière il y en a plus du tout alors
il y aura encore des palestiniens bien
évidemment dans un politiquement la base
de l'état à bâle berne et bâle et signa
malheureusement elle se fait de plus en
plus étroites d'ores et déjà risque
d'être re concentrés sur gaza qui elle
même un métier lui-même agnetha siéger
et qui n'a pas de aucune des
attributions et aucune des possibilités
d'un état indépendant puisqu'il est
encerclée par israël sur la mer est
bleue
et paraît sur la terre soit pas on voit
pas très bien comment ça peut devenir un
état indépendant
quant à la cisjordanie je sais pas je ne
vois pas comment ça peut marcher
faudrait vraiment une révolution des
publi plots matic et une et il ya un
retour une révolution dire un retour du
droit international dans toute sa
splendeur et encore pour remettre sur le
h sur la route pour nature ses pieds une
solution politique à deux états
notamment
alors ne parlons plus des résolutions
des nations unies y en ait eu 80 90 ou
plus ou 100 150 entre des résolutions du
conseil de sécurité des recommandations
de l'assemblée générale pourtant israël
est un état catésis mission des nations
unies et qu'on ne les a pas respectées
quoi merci beaucoup ancien ambassadeur
de france merci